spreading good karma by getting the
community involved and giving back
it is really that simple and it's the
idea behind the karma box
program we have kirsten joyce standing
by joining us with some additional
details
about the karma box program which really
does some terrific work kirsten
yes brian a las vegas man who went
through his share of bad decisions and
challenges
has found a great way to give back and
help others at the same time
grant denton was born and raised in las
vegas after spending nine years as a
drug addict three of those years
homeless he says he now works as a
program developer
with recovering addicts in reno to get
them engaged in the community
a huge part of that recovery is giving
back
he built one karma box filling it with
non-perishable food
socks toiletries etc to help others and
the idea caught on and now there are
more than
35 in northern nevada and he's now
partnering with a young woman here in
las vegas to do the same here
whether it's a student group whether
it's a school whether it's a sewing
circle
whether it's a bowling group whatever it
is it allows people
to uh to give it gives us a platform to
where we can
give easily and even if you want to
adopt a box if you want to put a box in
front of your business
and promote that um that you know that
sense of that sense of giving
they have a fundraiser on their facebook
page right now asking for donations to
make these karma boxes
and fill them with items for the less
fortunate of course as a business you
can sponsor
and create your own if you're interested
in getting involved message them at
karmaboxproject.org or through the
karmabox facebook page denise